[MUSIC PLAYING]
SCOTT LEVINE: Univision now
has a direct-to-consumer
subscription
offering, and the goal
was to give access
to our audience
wherever they are,
whenever they want it.
When we really wanted
to innovate and push
the boundaries on our
subscription service,
we launched in-app
subscriptions for Google Play,
and we saw a pop immediately
of about three to four
times the conversion rate by
working with the Google team.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ELIE HABIB: When
we started Anghami,
we said we want to have a music
service which is convenient,
and all the music available.
In the Middle East,
it was a region
which was totally forgotten.
There was no really
good alternative.
So you have to pirate or pirate.
I mean, there was nothing else.
And if we actually
could succeed,
we'd be pirating the pirates.
For us, Google Play is the core.
We have over 81% of our
users today on Android.
Our growth strategy
goes around engaging
Android users to use the app
more so they can subscribe.
AHCENE AMROUZ: I think
that Google Play,
the main [INAUDIBLE] helped
the increase of subscription
conversion rates on [INAUDIBLE].
And we think that the main
explanation is the better user
experience.
Android has become
the main source
for downloads for a [INAUDIBLE].
Also, we see on
subscription conversion
an increase of 6% on Android
compared to other platforms.
KONRADIN BREYER: Freeletics
started with the vision
to make everyone the greatest
version of themselves.
And the way we do this is we're
trying to motivate and guide
them in a variety
of apps to reach
their physical and mental goals.
The reason why subscriptions
make a lot of sense for us
is not only from an
economic point of view,
but also because we want to
develop people in the long run.
We want to have a repeated
impact upon their life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SCOTT LEVINE: Working
with Google Play
and figuring out how to launch
a successful subscription
product, it's been great.
And that kind of
partnership is really
what we saw that
led to the success.
[MUSIC PLAYING]